I don't want to pretend anymore we don't
need to spend time together we don't
need to speak unless we're gonna talk to
each other properly like you you've done
some things that have really hurt me
like you never you never asked if there
was more to my story at college you
never asked if I was okay you were too
focused on how it affected you there's
so many things that we've never spoken
about and I don't know if we ever will
you know all this was gonna be yours I
mean it still will be but I meant to
irrelevant make a living from
I understand we all got our own paths
truth is I want you to do well I want
you to have a great life I love you but
I can't pretend either there are things
I disagree with another bit I'll be
honest I'm you know I am being prideful
when I resent the fact that I may never
be a grandparent now that's just the
truth it's hard for me to admit that I
have hurt you and that with my beliefs
and with all this going on I understand
I'm they have set myself up to lose you
and I've had to ask myself and God if
I'm ready for that
I do not want to lose you
well it doesn't feel like that I'm sick
of avoiding you I'm sick of talking
about nothing I'm sick of it I'm gay and
I'm your son and neither of those things
are going to change
ok so let's deal with that or let's call
it a day both of us would be ok but that
would be a shame I'm not changing
there's no changing me God knows I tried
so if you mean it if you really mean
that and you're not ready to lose me
and I'm sorry but you're gonna have to
be the one to change I understand
I'm gonna try
good Drive
[Music]